that all options are on the table with
respect to Iran and that's something
senator Clinton senator Edwards and
Obama have all said now they may not be
saying it now because the drumbeat of
war is louder but they said it at a time
when the bush administration was looking
to see who would support their ideas
about build up towards war against Iran
so senator Clinton senator Edwards and
Senator Obama have all licensed the Bush
administration's build-up to war against
Iran and it is very dangerous the Bush
administration is no this is at this
point it's it's it's well known that
they're talking about retrofitting b-2
stealth bombers with 30,000 pound bombs
to be dropped on nuclear research labs
in Iran the dirty bomb you could call it
you could call it a another Chernobyl in
the making I call it a war crime and we
have we have officials in the White
House who have already committed war
crimes by planning an attack on a nation
that did not attack us and by planning
to drop a weapon that will have a
catastrophic effect that will release
radiation when it's dropped on these
nuclear research lab they'll be a
radiation release that will go perhaps
hundreds even thousands of miles that
will poison the land and poison maybe
millions of people there's another
question here it's not what's the most
dangerous idea that I've heard question
is what's our conscience
you